Star Trek the card opens with a host of
mysteries many of which have been
unraveled but there's still a lot that's
been left unsaid
here are the biggest unanswered
questions from season 1 of Star Trek
Picard at the end of Picard season one
finale the heroes are on board La Sirena
presumably on their way back home
captain Rios and dr. Zarate seemed to be
continuing their relationship while a
new romance appears to be blooming
between seven of nine and Rafi Picard
and so she are there as well as the
Romulan warrior Eleanor but will this
cruise stay together after all none of
them are active Starfleet officers La
Sirena has no extended mission to
explore anything jarate came aboard as a
spy for the shot vash rios has more than
completed the job Picard's paying him
for and Elmore has concluded the mission
he vowed to help Picard complete ranvier
house through Jacques Piccard rekelen
guy we're guessing something will pop up
in season 2 if Picard to keep its
titular hero in the Stars and in the
meantime the writers have provided the
glue for these characters to stay
together even though Eleanor only
officially agreed to the mission to save
Shoji he idolizes Picard and we'll
probably go wherever the retired Admiral
does jarate has romantic reasons to stay
onboard La Sirena as de7 as for Shoji
after learning that her life on earth
was a sham why not follow her new real
life friends on other adventures one
character who is conspicuously missing
from the end of Picard season one finale
is narak the Romulan spy spent most of
the season seducing Shoji so he could
manipulate her into triggering her
memories and revealing the location of
her homeworld eventually we learned that
while narak and other members of the
shot Vash are merciless their goal isn't
without merit they mean to stop a
galactic apocalypse they call ganma dan
which they believe will be caused by a
higher order of synthetics called the
synthetic alliance that Shoji and her
brethren mean to summit the last we see
of narak he and some of the heroes had
tried and failed to destroy the
synthetics beacon we don't see him
aboard La Sirena when it leaves and the
shot Vash fleet leaves cap elías without
beaming him up a card showrunner Michael
Chabon addressed this through his
Instagram apparently there wasn't enough
time to show the resolution to narak
story which presumably would include
learning seven of nine killed his sister
in an Instagram story Shae bond wrote
yeah narak
we know we know
a casualty of the editorial process alas
the intention was for him to be taken
into Federation custody that doesn't
necessarily mean that will prove to be
what happened however since we never saw
it happen the writers could always
choose a different fate for the sneaky
Romulan the season 1 finale of Picard
has its heroes facing two opposing
threats on one hand there's a massive
Romulan fleet ready to destroy everyone
and everything on the planet Capelli's
on the other there's the synthetic
alliance that so she means to summon to
protect her and other since
unfortunately the Alliance's method of
protecting other synthetic life is to
eradicate all organic life Romulan human
and everything in between we don't see
much of the Alliance but were shown
enough to be convinced of the danger
after the portal opens we see huge
mechanical tentacles reaching out Picard
convinces Scioscia to shut down the
beacon and close the portal
keeping whatever was on the other end of
those tendrils in their own corner of
the universe we're left without knowing
much about the synthetic alliance how
did it come into being where are they
from how many of them are there do they
truly mean to wipe out all organic life
or have we misunderstood their
intentions but perhaps the most pressing
question of all is now that they know
about the sins on cap Elias will we be
seeing them again
Stardust City rag has possibly the most
shocking ending of any episode in
Picard's first season after being
reunited with her colleague and lover
Bruce Maddox doctor jarate murders him
in La Sirena sick bay in Nepenthe we
learned that the shot Vash spica Maduro
approached her on earth before jarate
joined La Sirena screw and used a mind
meld to give her a vision of the
galactic apocalypse the shot vas fear
once the other heroes learn of jarate x'
betrayal they initially seem eager to
get her off the ship Picard has every
intention of turning her into the
Federation later they seem more
understanding believing she was not in
control of her actions when she murdered
Maddux shortly after the airing of the
season finale Michael Chabon answered
fan questions for Trek movie comm while
the season ends without jarate being
arrested shave on clarified she will put
herself in the hands of the law so we
know jarate intends to take
responsibility for what she did though
it remains to be seen what legal
consequences she'll have to face then
again the federation has changed it
might be tough to predict what they'll
do along with seven some other Star Trek
alums show up in the first season of
Picard
data appears several times we get to see
Riker make pizza and Deanna Troi proves
as insightful as ever we even get a
chance to see Jonathan del arco reprised
the recurring next-generation role of
Hugh a Borg drone who becomes an
individual but what about everyone else
Wesley Crusher was nowhere to be found
in the story even though Wil Wheaton
hosted Picard's after-show the ready
room we don't hear from Beverly Crusher
wharf or Geordi LaForge
nor do we know what any of them have
been doing in the intervening years Worf
got a new job in the series finale for
Star Trek Deep Space 9 but we don't know
whether he still holds the position or
if he's moved on commander how would you
feel about being named Federation
ambassador to Chronos I am NOT a
diplomat additionally there are still
plenty of fans wondering whether their
favorite characters from Deep Space nine
and Voyager will ever make an appearance
in future episodes of Picard we haven't
seen voyagers former Captain Kathryn
Janeway since her cameo in 2002 Star
Trek nemesis and there are plenty of
questions we'd love to have answered
about the rest of the Voyager crew is
the doctor still around would Chakotay
Torres and other former Maquis crew have
to answer for their crimes after
returning to earth then there are the
Deep Space nine alums
besides Worf we haven't seen any of the
regular cast of ds9 reappear in a trek
production since the series finale
though star dust city rag shows us that
quark has moved his operations to free
cloud asked which to ds9 characters he
would bring a board La Sirena if he
could Michael Chabon named the enigmatic
exiled spy Garak and the Cardassian best
friend dr. Bashir at least one
next-generation cast member has already
agreed to show up in season two the day
before Picard series premiere aired on
CBS all access Patrick Stewart appeared
on the view to invite co-host Whoopi
Goldberg to reprise her role of Guinan
for Picard second season
[Applause]
with the revelation that the synthetic
attack on Mars was orchestrated by the
Shot Vash the federation lifts its ban
on synthetic life in the Picard Season
Finale that's good news for Picard who
is now a synthetic life-form himself but
while allowing synthetics to exist in
the Federation may be the right thing to
do it doesn't seem likely everyone is
going to be comfortable with it the
attack on Mars is portrayed as a deeply
traumatic event for the Federation we
learned the fires caused by the assault
still rage on the red planet 14 years
later it's difficult to imagine that
with so much loss of life there won't be
a vocal group of Federation citizens
against the bans lifting it seems likely
it will be a long time before the
Federation sees sense in regular use as
they were at the Utopia Planitia
shipyards the card might find himself
the target of anti synthetic prejudice
what will happen when those closest to
Picard find out that biologically
speaking he's no longer human
especially considering Picard is the
same man who unwittingly helped the Borg
almost bring the Federation to its knees
after Picard's assimilation by the Borg
and subsequent rescue in the next
generations two-parter at the best of
both worlds
dr. crusher removes his Borg implants
but it's clear he still retains some
connection to the collective for example
in first contact he dreams of the Borg
shortly before learning of their new
assault on the Federation and he guesses
they're on their way before Starfleet
tells him during the battle with the
Borg cube he knows exactly what part of
the enemy ship to strike and in Picard's
first season he recognizes the layout of
the Queen cell in the Borg artifact
despite never having been there before
but the cards first season ends with the
heroes consciousness transferred into a
synthetic body which means ironically
becoming fully synthetic may have
finally freed him from his connection
with the Borg we don't know exactly what
it was that kept his link to the
collective alive but it seems reasonable
that whatever it was would not carry
over to his new body of course
anything's possible in Star Trek and we
could eventually learn they're still a
part of Luke yudice within Picard but
maybe his goal to get back to the rest
of his humanity somehow needed him
physically speaking to lose it the seven
of nine we meet in Picard is very much a
changed woman since her days aboard
Voyager in voyager 17 check as much as a
Vulcan while in Picard 7 expresses
powerful emotions speaking to sci-fi
wire Jeri Ryan said the moment 7 finds
each ebb & Mersey kills him in stardust
city rag is probably the first time that
seven truly let go of her emotions but
that leads us to a big question how are
sevens powerful emotions even possible
in the Voyager episode human error seven
uses holographic simulations to help
with her social skills and to continue
exploring her humanity eventually we
learned that experimenting with emotion
is more dangerous than she realizes the
doctor reveals her Borg implants include
a fail-safe that will shut down her
higher brain functions if her emotions
are stimulated too much but I'm no
longer linked to the hive mind
the technologies built into your node it
simply remained dormant from what we've
seen in Picard's version of seven that
failsafe definitely should have gone off
if it's still active
maybe after so many years of separation
from the Borg the failsafe stopped
working or maybe she finally allowed the
doctor or someone else to perform the
necessary surgery to deactivate it
regardless Picard doesn't give us the
answer a cards first season ends with
the shot Vash planned to annihilate the
synthetics foiled however their ultimate
goal of preventing the galactic
apocalypse they believed the synthetic
alliance will cause is still achieved
when Picard convinces shoji to destroy
the beacon and close the portal to the
higher order of synths faced with the
prospect of a battle with a Starfleet
Armada the Romulans leave cap alias
unscathed what happens to the shot Vash
now they've operated for centuries
within the Tau Shiar but now their
existence has been brought to light it
isn't clear whether they're officially
sanctioned by the Romulan government if
not then they've made a target of
themselves not only did they almost
bring the Romulan Empire to war with the
Federation but they failed in their
mission the Romulan Empire is not the
kind of place where failure is rewarded
or even tolerated with ganma Dan averted
there's technically no longer any reason
for the shot Vash to exist though we're
willing to bet they could find a reason
to keep going after all Derek's sister
Nerissa showed us that at least some of
the shot Vash find any kind of
artificial life disgusting sadly that
kind of hatred usually defies logic and
finds a way to thrive check out one of
our newest videos right here plus even
more looper videos about Star Trek are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]